my name is steve
thank you very much for having me it's a
pleasure to be here
i'm really excited to be giving this
talk
entitled music information retrieval
using
scikit-learn i know that there's maybe a
broad range of
levels uh expertise levels when it comes
to machine learning and numerical
analysis in this audience uh so i'm
going to keep it somewhat introductory
but hopefully not too introductory so if
you have any questions
that are on either side of
the technical level of this talk please
feel free to ask
so first of all a special thanks to tony
for allowing me to speak today special
thanks to thumbtack you have an awesome
office here it's very
san francisco web 2.0 startup i don't
know it was really cool uh so thanks a
lot for having me and thanks a lot for
the food i'd like to thank a person
named jayla buff he was my boss at uh
imagine research which was purchased by
izotope he now runs a non-profit called
real industry
and a lot of the material was
borrowed from a workshop that he and i
co-instruct at
ccrma the center for computer research
and music and acoustics at stanford
university we do this every summer it's
one week uh around june and july uh i
i've been doing this since 2011 and he's
been doing it since 2008. we would love
for you guys to come so when you uh
when when the time rolls around next
year uh take a look on the karma website
i'll tell you uh where that is and
hopefully we'll see you there
i'd also like to thank owen with whom i
worked he was also a participant at that
workshop and uh he's now a master's
student at ucsb focus on the music
information retrieval and he helped
develop some of the materials today
this photo is from the karma workshop
what you see this is my boss jay
and this is
a beautiful adobe air
interface
of a music recommendation system where
it would
if you query it with a particular
acoustic audio based query it would
return for you sound effects such as
bloodlust and napalm blitz whatever that
is
so furthermore
a lot of that workshop had roots in
matlab we're trying to modernize it by
bringing it to
you know the 21st century so we uh
changed a lot of material over to python
and you can find a lot of the material
in that workshop as well as material in
this talk at
my github profile which i can i can
share that with you
uh by email after the talk if like so
it's not necessary take notes but you're
welcome to plug
so that's on uh github and this
is basically a collection of ipython
notebooks
a few of which you'll see later on
furthermore to facilitate
the
startup effort in getting up and running
especially during the workshop when
people just want to get coding
immediately
we have a vagrant box
which allows people to just once you
have vagrant on whatever host os you're
using mac windows or linux you can just
load the box which is a virtual machine
on virtualbox and all of the
dependencies relate to python and
scikit-learn and more will be
automatically
taken care of for you
so that is linked from the github page
okay uh real quick i'm from new jersey
anyone here from new jersey oh right on
yeah garden state yeah exactly
where wherein
i just graduated
okay excellent and how are you
madison okay i'm north how about you
wayne okay all right we should we should
hang out okay cool uh my next 11 years
were spent at the university of maryland
any terps in the house
okay that's fine
yeah
one for two that's fine um i studied
electrical engineering there and uh did
some work in image forensics and music
information retrieval my uh
thesis was in the area of music
transcription i'll talk more about that
later on i came here to san francisco in
2011 to work with a company i mentioned
before imagine research we were building
a web-based audio recognition engine not
specifically for music
like your app shazam will it will tell
you that this is madonna or something no
but rather just for general audio
something that can tell you the sound of
an explosion or jazz music or female
speech or a baby crying
uh so that was purchased by isotope in
march of 2012 in june of 2013 i went and
did the independent thing
and in 2014 i joined a company
called humtap and oh i didn't load this
yet
let's see if this works
so we just redid the webpage like this
past week so i hope the vimeo video
still
works
hello i'm thomas from hamta and i'm jan
from hum tab think about 30 years ago
you needed a big expensive studio to
record a song today you can have all
that gear in the laptop that's why many
people say that everyone can make music
nowadays but the truth is you still need
a lot of knowledge and you still need a
lot of gear
but what if you could just hum a melody
like
da
da da da da da
and then have someone else tap a beat
and finally you select a genre and
that's all you need to create a little
tune
now personally i'm more into electronic
music so let me change the genre and see
what we get
that's the cheesiest video ever but
like i
i laugh every time i see it it's just so
wonderful
uh so this is company i work with and
there are some other things i'm not
liberty to talk about that i'm working
on at this company but as you can tell
there must be some music information
retrieval going on in real time on the
back end and i
help with that
okay so this term music information
retrieval what is that well i'm going to
play some audio for you
and i'd like you
to yell out as many musical attributes
no matter how rudimentary
uh how elementary they are just if it
comes to your mind yell it out
what instruments are there
steel string snare drum
male singer thank you
let's do that again
yeah maybe a tad bit faster i think yeah
okay how about this one
what chord progression
i think one
uh yeah one six four five right
uh who's the singer
i think it's paul mccartney if i'm not
mistaken
what instrument
yeah i know
what key
it's like british accent right i think
it's key of c i'm not mistaken
okay how about mood like what what how
does this make you feel what adjectives
come to mind
melancholy yeah absolutely but maybe
also just a little bit like of
hopefulness or optimism but you know the
lyrics gospel
yeah it's a little bit gospely yeah i
would say that okay uh what about this
okay it's rachmaninoff wraps video
themed by paganini uh what else can you
tell me about it either by listening or
just by looking at it
what key is it in
five flats i know so not a common one d
flat major
uh what's a time signature
a slow three
how does it make you feel
labels
it's it's pretty it's uh
i'm sorry
nostalgic yeah that's a good one
where are we
lot of rubato
hard to capture the rhythm it's in a
slow three but it it
it speeds up and slows down okay
excellent
uh okay thanks a lot for your
participation this just illustrates that
these are the problems that we're trying
to solve by teaching computers these
sorts of labels how do we teach a
computer what it means to
have rubato or for it to be in 3 4 or d
flat major or classical or a leading
male vocal those are all very difficult
human attributes that we're trying to
feed into the computer that's music
information retrieval amongst other
things it involves problems such as
music fingerprinting can you tell me
that this is the exact recording by
uh stephen huff playing
off cover song detection maybe i just
don't want exactly stephen huff's
recording but i just want to know that
it is a work by rachmaninoff perhaps to
be on thing by paganini but recorded by
somebody else genre recognition is it
classical rock pop reggae so forth
transcription can you get me each and
every single beat every single musical
event including its start time its
duration its instrument label and its
loudness
recommendation if you like rachmaninoff
you might also like tchaikovsky symbolic
melodic similarity not in the acoustic
domain but maybe once we're in the
symbolic domain and we're just looking
at the discrete sequence of symbols we
might want to infer some sort of
similarity notion between these two
strings
mood is it nostalgic upbeat angry happy
sad source separation it sure be nice if
we could just
extract the drum loop
from the full mix or just extract the
foreground and there's a lot else that
we can do with either the foreground or
the background
instrument recognition we have to maybe
figure out if we're going to do a lot of
these other things what's in
the full mix is there a piano is there a
drum is there a flute is there a vocal
pitch tracking to get uh
any
uh voiced or pitched instrument along
with its pitch contour tempo estimation
uh
yeah is it 60 beats per minute 120 100
score alignment if you have a symbolic
version and an acoustic version of a
piece of music maybe you'd like to you
know like see like a red cursor that
goes along the score as you're listening
to it because when you see something
while listening to to it
you hear different things
you hear new things you hear things that
you wouldn't hear otherwise if you're
looking at the score at the same time
like the one i showed you in the
previous slide
song structure form is in sonata form is
it aba is it verse refrain
uh what is the overall global structure
of the piece of music
be tracking can you give me when the
beat occurs
that's the beat
key detection is in d flat major c major
c minor
query by humming can you just go da da
da da da and have it return rock man and
off rapidly on team by paganini these
are just some of the problems in music
information retrieval
and it's more than just an academic
exercise today in 2014 there are quite a
lot of companies now that deal in some
small part or large part in music
information retrieval for example
youtube for copyright detection you'll
say oh you can't use the song you gotta
pay up or whatever
shazam
you probably already know adobe is doing
a lot of interesting audio research uh
just couple blocks away from here at 7th
and townsend that they're trying to put
into their products that they are
putting into their product
pandora recommendation
rdo also race note uh more on a
b2b level with uh other large companies
putting into cars and stuff like that
um
so echo nest is this company which
may be the most mir company out there at
least until its acquisition several
months ago by spotify
they were a music analytics service
where you could
upload a piece of music and it would
give you this huge json response
containing all of its low-level musical
attributes
uh they were founded in 2005 and so just
uh nine years or so after their founding
they were purchased by spotify and it's
a they were already partners before that
and it makes sense for
someone with so much
musical data to be partnering with
someone who can analyze that data
uh soundtown which does things similar
to shazam but a little bit different
melodyne
is arguably the best commercial music
transcription software out there
that being said it still lives leaves a
lot to be desired and music
transcription is a devilishly difficult
problem and it's something that
grad students all around the world are
trying to add their increment to the
huge body of research to make it better
okay so that's mir
oh why python because it's not matlab
i don't even have a point behind that
slide it's uh
you know uh
we all know
the advantages of python is it's free
it's got a great community a lot of
libraries one of which is scikit-learn
which we'll look at later
as well as the ipython notebook which is
kind of like the matlab desktop we'll
take a look at that later
so
throughout this talk i'll use a common
architecture for the mr problems that
we'll talk about
i'll focus mostly on music transcription
because that's just what i happen to
know best and you'll see how it follows
how it falls into this paradigm so first
we have a piece of audio
literally a wav file or something like
it
audio files are variable length
just like an image can have variable
dimensions audio also has variable
dimensions and if you need to
standardize your analysis you're going
to need to segment it somehow in some
meaningful way that could either be
uniformly sized frames or
variable
frames with a variable hop size
once you've somehow chosen your frames
then you need to extract features from
each frame depending upon the task that
you're trying to solve if you want to do
genre recognition for example then you
might extract something called the mel
frequency capture coefficients
which just kind of give you an overall
idea of
the timbre of the sound the overall type
of sound without regards to its pitch
if you want to do pitch tracking then
obviously you have to get some pitch
related features
and then finally
some
notion of machine learning whether
that's classification or not
that will yield some sort of musical
information
depending upon what we're trying to
solve
so more graphically here we have an
audio signal which is literally just a
it's an array internally
uh
with elements between negative one and
one
sound all sound is
air vibrating
sound is fluctuation and air pressure
when when when i'm speaking it's hitting
your eardrum and that fluctuation in
pressure is sending signals to your
brain and that's what you're hearing
that's what's being represented here as
well
so you can partition or segment your
input audio into uniformly sized frames
such as this as i mentioned before
or
maybe you just want to look at
whenever each onset
occurs
so
for example
if there were a way that we could detect
onsets then maybe we don't need to worry
about all this nonsense in the middle
and we can just focus on the relevant
musical information
however we've chosen our framing
strategy next we want to do some feature
extraction
so for example one one
example of a feature can be the zero
crossing rate
it's a simple
time domain based
uh
feature and it's literally just the
number of times
per unit time that a signal crosses the
x-axis
so perhaps looking at this previous
slide it might make sense that these
kick drums had a lower zero crossing
rate than the snare drums so maybe
that's a meaningful feature
maybe we want to look at the spectral
domain figure out the look at the
frequency content and somehow
parameterize the shape over of the
overall spectrum maybe we want to get
the
centroid like the spectral mean
maybe the spectral spread
or the spectral slope or other things
related to higher order statistics of
the spectrum
however we've chosen our features then
we want to do some sort of a
classification method
where after we've
collected the features of all of our
examples we can do something maybe
clustering or
svm or whatever that can tell you that
these examples
represent a kick drum and these
represent a snare drum
okay
making it a little bit more concrete in
psychic learn
there are several things you can use
for those who are
not too familiar with scikit-learn i
think there are just a couple of
takeaways that i'd like to present today
one is that what's nice about
scikit-learn which uh
i don't know i think it's fair to say is
maybe the most popular
machine learning library in python today
it's it's better or worse in certain
aspects but uh it's very very popular
uh it has this common interface for
classifiers
here this thing that i just call model
regardless of whether you're using
any of these in this case seven examples
that i've put on the slide
they all have a common
notion of training using a method called
fit
and testing using a method called
predict so you can easily swap
classifiers and see which ones work
better in different scenarios
so
you choose a classifier initialize it
you get a whole bunch of training data
extract its features train the model and
then give it a novel audio example get
its features and make a prediction
so we're about to see how this can be
done
in python and i'm going to do this
inside the ipython notebook which once
again
uh is
like um the matlab desktop but it's in
the browser and it's free it doesn't
cost a thousand dollars and so you don't
have to bittorrent it so
it's notebook time
running
uh
in
safari
and
uh
so first thing i'd like to show is just
an example of some common things
that we can do with using audio signals
what i'm doing in this introductory
notebook
is
i'm getting an audio signal which sounds
like this
yes
i'm sorry
thank you for the recommendation
how's that
okay great
thanks for letting me know
so it sounds like this
okay so
a lot of drums there
and
uh
so this
audio file which in this case i put into
the array called song it's literally as
i mentioned an array and it looks like
this
this is the time domain representation
we can also plot something called a
spectrogram which shows the evolution of
frequency content
over time
i understand i'm using some terms that
may not be clear to everyone if you have
any questions feel free to ask me
at any time
so after we've
read the audio file in
we can do some pretty neat stuff using
an open source library called essentia
this is
essentia
has come out of the music technology
group mtg out of the university pompeo
fabra in barcelona spain and
that is a very prolific group in mir
they've done a lot of amazing stuff over
the past 30 years or more
and one of them is essentia
it has these like c plus plus roots but
a python binding around it
uh which is good enough
and so here what we can do is identify
the onsets detect the onsets whenever a
beat a drum beat occurs and what we have
are a list of times here in units of
seconds
so these are the onsets
and then what i'm going to do just to
show that
the onset detection worked is i'm going
to superimpose a beep
for each onset upon the original audio
so let's see if it worked
pretty good not perfect
so then
question yes please
uh great question the question was how
does that onset detector work black box
for the purpose of this talk but you can
go to uh
you can go inside the code and there
will be a link to the specific paper
where they get the algorithm if you're
interested uh in general i think this
has a mode where there are several onset
detector algorithms that you can choose
from
uh it's probably some combination of
both evolution and energy as well as
a first order difference in the
frequency content because when you uh if
you're playing a slur on a violin the
loudness stays the same but you're
changing notes so some combination of
that i think this particular algorithm
to get specific has mostly to do with
loudness
questions
a great question the question was can
you get probabilities back from the
onset detector meaning not just on or
off but rather how likely is it yes
there is some notion of confidence that
they also output
maybe with an auxiliary function not the
ones that i'm using here uh but uh they
call it may not be probabilities in some
rigorous sense but rather a novelty
curve and the novelty curve is the
intermediate
variable that they use to infer onsets
in fact so yes there is some other thing
you can work with yes good question
after that let's
uh
partition our input audio into segments
here i'm using a list comprehension in
python something that
is a really con in my opinion convenient
way to do
partitioning of an array in python just
as a one-liner
so
for every
on set using units of samples in
this variable called onset samples
that is the segment that i'm extracting
okay
uh
and then what i'm going to do
uh ignore this nonsense then going down
here
is extract the zero crossing rate again
using essentia
using this function
we're going to get the zero crossing
rate for each segment
and these are all the zero crossing
rates
so finally
what i think is interesting is what
happened if you would
sort
all of the frames
by its zero crossing rate i think that
would give you some physical
interpretation as to what zero crossing
rate is
so it sounds something like this
you heard the snares in the hats toward
the end right in the kick drums in the
beginning
uh
okay i'm going to speed up a little bit
it is now 759 yes please go ahead so it
seems
intuitively would think the zero
crossing as it
has a relationship to uh
the pitch or spectral content
spectral content in some sense yes
generally that's not necessarily true uh
it's uh it does have more to do with
timbre but there you can make counter
examples with certain types of
instruments where uh
pitch does not have as direct of an
effect on the zero crossing rate as uh
you might otherwise think yeah
in short that's a good question
uh so next the actual okay so you didn't
see any scikit-learn here but let me
show you
something that does use scikit-learn
okay
what we're going to do here is now
supervised classification of drum beats
what i'm going to do
is after importing a whole bunch of junk
from scikit-learn and essentia
i have a couple of
training files of kick drums
training files of snare drums
and
i'm defining
a feature extraction
function
all you need to know is that given a
frame
it's going to compute the zero crossing
rate something called the spectral
centroid as well as some higher order
statistical moments of the spectrum and
it's just going to return a five element
feature vector for a frame
then some more details and nonsense
and
uh in scikit-learn
there's this pre-processing module which
you'll want to use especially when
dealing with audio signals because
you have different features that are in
different units zero crossing rate is on
some unit and and spectral centroid is
on a totally different dimension you're
going to want to normalize them so
there's this convenience convenient
thing called uh
scalars
l e r scalar
in the pre-processing module where for
example you can scale all the features
to lie between negative one and one
so that's what we've done here
and after
once we've defined our training labels
and features
then what i'm going to do
is
okay first just
plot the training features by class
i'm plotting
all of the
snare drums
they're here and all the kick drums or
reverse kick drums and snare drums
on at least just for these two
dimensions just to show you that they
are separable
okay so next
we are going to
initialize a model
so back to that block diagram that we
had initialized model was up here we're
initializing a model
and
then we're training it using the
features and the corresponding labels
and then given a
novel this is not novel but a novel
example you just call predict and it
will give you the predicted label
and a nice thing about scikit-learn is
that there's this method called score
where all you have to do is
feed in a novel set of features and
labels and it'll tell you
uh the overall accuracy of uh of those
of that collection
obviously you don't want to do it on the
training features but this is just a
good sanity check
okay so now testing it
we're going to test it with a novel set
of
uh files
again we're just going to extract
features for each of those
uh kick and snare samples and in this
notebook all of those files are just
single hits they sound like boom or
so that's true of all the training and
test files
again we apply the same scaling
so the same scaling that was used in
training before is applied to the test
examples
and then
we
just use model.score
on the test features and test labels and
there you go you've got a model that you
can
now use for
drumbeat classification
if instead i wanted to change
k neighbors
k nearest neighbor classifier to
either an svm
logistic regression
naive bayes or even adaboost you can do
that so
let's just try adaboost so adaboost in
this context
uh of scikit-learn adaboost combines a
lot of weak classifiers together
that actually happens internally by the
defaults
let me run this because it will take a
moment
but the point is that the interface is
the same as all the other ones that you
see
so
uh while this is running is anybody here
a good beat boxer can you beatbox anyone
want no yeah no okay
yeah oh okay so sort of okay we'll sort
okay thanks for volunteering uh if if if
you'd like to come up to the front
you're welcome to you
okay nice nice nice nice there we go
there we go
okay i'd like you to beat box just uh
once i
hit
record on this terminal so now i've got
a terminal where i'm going to record
his
uh let's go to stand for test
and we're going to record test.wave
so so something so actually let's make
that beat
box dot wave so let me just give an
example uh
right and so it'll sound like
okay so you got something in your head
it can be short it and just just two
drums if you could
specifically a kick drum and a snare
drum would be great okay
so you can hit enter whenever you're
ready
okay thank you very much thank you
okay excellent so let's see what happens
now
uh when
we
use that
on
test beatbox.wave
okay uh
so
the ipython notebook is very
resource intensive so you'll see the
spinning wheel a lot
but what's going to happen is that we're
going to do onset detection on the beats
and then we're going to classify each
segment using the aforementioned
classifier
i can't even move my cursor okay there
we go
okay let's hope this works
so i'm gonna run this
oh
uh i think
sorry if you don't mind just waiting 10
more seconds
i'm going to run all just to be super
safe
um
while that is running if i can do
control tab let's skip ahead to k means
clustering
so if you don't have labels then you
might want to do something unsupervised
uh
how much time do i have right now it's
808.
uh okay
there's a drum machine 808. oh 808. so
sorry i'm i'm really i'm actually not an
audio file so it's like when i'm at work
i just sometimes it's just plugins i
don't know how that works
so
thanks
if you don't have labels you can apply
something unsupervised just a moment
thank you
such as k-means clustering or there are
a lot of other clustering methods in
scikit-learn
some of them you don't even need to tell
how many clusters
you have it will be able to guess it for
you using some criterion
so let's see what happens if we if we
use this again
okay so let's extract
the
zero crossing rate and in this
uh case the energy the loudness of a
particular frame
here's what the audio looks like in the
time domain
and now what i'm plotting here is the
zero crossing rate for each frame of
that piece of audio so indeed
there's a high zero crossing rate for
the snare drums and a low one for the
kick drum but it's non-zero
over here
and now here's the energy we see maybe
higher energy for the kick drum a little
bit and lower for the snare drum
we're going to do the same notion of
scaling between negative one and one
you can also scale using zero mean and
unit variance there are a lot of ways to
scale
and then we're just going to scatter
plot the features
on
uh the two-dimensional future space and
indeed it looks like this
so what happens if we cluster this so
i'm going to use k means
i'm going to tell it the number of
clusters and indeed let's see what we
have here
you have something like kick
silence
snare
kick
kick
snare
so indeed it matches our expectations
and if we were to color code the results
it may be a little bit difficult from
where you're sitting but these are
yellow these are red and these are black
okay
now just to illustrate the point that
you can use another type of unsupervised
method there's something called affinity
propagation but to be honest i don't
exactly know how it works but the point
is that it clusters in a different way
and so let's consider this audio signal
we're going to do the same stuff extract
the onsets
convert them to units of samples we're
going to get the segments at each onset
we're going to compute
those zero crossing rate and energy for
each segment
and then we're going to scale them
and this time
we're going to apply
affinity propagation
and you'll notice that
we're just using some parameter here
that does not have to do with the number
of clusters but rather once we uh apply
them
uh
to the input features
these are the labels that we get for
each segment i should mention that in
the previous example you saw frames that
are uniformly spaced these are at each
onset so in this case you'll notice that
there are labels between 0 and 5.
so here when i scatter plot
there are six colors here
and let's
superimpose a beep
upon all of the
magenta these are magenta
so magenta is label five
and that's label five here let's see
which drums that picks out
i think it's a higher higher pitched
ones maybe let's uh instead try
is that black
black is labeled zero
so
zero
this may be like low to mid-range or
something like that
okay
uh let's go back to our supervised
classification hopefully it's gone oh oh
geez oh oh that's not good
spinning wheel of death
i was thinking about being the blue
screen of death for halloween but it's
like i got that idea a little bit too
late
so but they do sell that oh there we go
okay
maybe the volume was just a little bit
too low for it to only get these onsets
but let's uh see what happened
it got your snares so so good job okay
great job
you got it got your snares
uh yeah i guess that's all him right the
idea is that then we would
uh
uh only detect yeah okay so here
uh
all of the detected onsets were snare
drums is what it's saying here
so this would be nonsense this isn't
gonna result in any
beeps right
okay
demo effect
uh okay so i would ah of all the things
i'd like to show
uh let me quickly show
uh how non-negative matrix factory
factorization can be used to do source
separation
there is something in scikit-learn
decomposition called nmf which stands
for non-negative matrix factorization it
is a factorization technique
that factorizes an input matrix such as
a spectrogram into a product of two
other matrices
here is what it actually looks like if
you have an input spectrogram that looks
like this literally represented as a
two-dimensional array a matrix
internally
then if you feed it into
nmf
again you may need to define the number
of components
train it
and then apply it to the input
spectrogram
what you'll see
are
two matrices w and h
where
the columns of w
correspond to the spectral content
of the audio so here we're plotting on
over frequency access
the spectrum
that has been extracted in this case
using two components from the input
audio
so again this is using our boom boom
boom
so here we have a snare drum and a kick
drum
and then the neat part is that the other
matrix h the two rows of the matrix h
correspond to the temporal activations
the energy profile of the kick drum and
the snare drum and indeed that's what
you see here kick snare kick snare
from that since you have this notion of
separation you can combine individual
components of the factorization to
isolate the kick drum or the snare drum
so if you uh
apply this on more complicated signals
you'll need a wiser strategy for
choosing the number of components and
there's a lot of engineering involved
but this is a very popular technique
which was pioneered around 1999 or 2001
in the area of biology and it was only
around 2003 since then that's been
applied to musical signals and now it's
a very hot uh area of research so if you
were i don't know so much now in 2014
but back in like 2008 2010
uh nmf was a very hot thing to do
so
the final thing that i would like to fit
in if you would oblige
is that the right word if if you would
uh
bear with me
is
music fingerprint music fingerprinting
this doesn't have that much to do with
scikit-learn however there is a neat
thing called uh gaussian random product
projection
you can do random projections on your
own but scikit-learn makes it a little
bit more convenient
through this
function here
so the purpose of this notebook is to do
music fingerprinting something that
uh
i won't go into the detail on too much
but it uses a method called locality
sensitive hashing and we can talk
offline about how that works
but
the main point is that it
involves some sort of a hash function
by applying a random projection
upon feature vectors
then you threshold the output of that
random projection and there's a nice
probabilistic theory behind it that
shows uh some correspondence between
the closeness of features in the feature
space
and the closeness of their corresponding
hashes that's what makes them locality
sensitive if two features are close
in the feature space then it is likely
that they'll be closed in
the hash space
so using scikit-learn you can uh use
uh that to do your random projections
blah blah blah you can go onto github to
see how this works
but what i have now at the bottom is
some is a music search class and if we
feed it something like
this
uh play steve
03.
it would get you a list of results
now
let's see
how this works
uh in real time so i'm going to
play something for you hopefully
i'm not warmed up and i didn't cut my
nails and you should cut your nails if
you're going to play the violin but
sorry
uh okay let's see let's try i'm gonna
play
uh
something by bach the
uh partito number three third movement
and i may need to stand a little bit
further away to do this okay
okay and so now thank you
so
we're going to change that to test
wave and hopefully if it works
uh so i didn't hit enter yet but i'm
going to point out cover my ass
disclaimer that this is a randomized
algorithm so if it doesn't work it's the
algorithm's fault okay so uh let's let's
uh hit enter
uh fantastic so there we got a
uh partita number three first movement
by uh
these people and those people there
let's try
one more
i'll do a
sonata number three uh the third
movement also by bach
okay so that's also in test.wave and so
that was again sonata number three
by ba uh
it's probably down there somewhere
so let's run that
come on
okay
crossing yes here we go so now number
three third movement
uh by those people
uh
i'm gonna end on a make because it's
rare that that goes two for two
so
all
uh
thank you
uh
let's see so going on right now
in
taiwan
is ismir
and it sure be nice if you could see it
okay
going on right now second day just
second day concluded uh ismir is the
flagship conference for music
information retrieval it rotates all
around the world from
portugal to miami to
brazil baltimore
and
really cool stuff there so you can check
out all the conference proceedings
they're all online for free
mirex is a
evaluation a contest where different mir
algorithms are pitted against one
another
data is a very difficult issue in music
information retrieval because
obviously there's a recording industry
you can't just disseminate commercial
music
and so they have a standardized way of
evaluating different algorithms and you
can go there to see which algorithms
perform the best on a whole bunch of
different tasks
karma workshop if you want to come be
part of our 2015
workshop
please uh
keep an eye out for karma.stanford.edu
for those who are into google scholar
then you can check out any of these
journals or
conference proceedings even icml and
nips there
occasionally some things that have to do
with music
which are really interesting
finally what is the range of a viola
as far as you can kick it
thank you very much for your time
happy happy to answer any questions you
have
questions
i heard part of that is there any work
on what part of feature extraction
oh yeah is there any work on automated
feature extraction uh yeah that's that's
also a hot topic right now being able to
uh you know it's a little bit fragile
when you and me humans are trying to
determine in the audio space which audio
features are most relevant that being
said if you just go fully from the
spectrum and expect a
deep learning model to learn the exact
things for you
it's there are just so many different
tasks in music information retrieval
that are so different that it's there's
i don't know no way that you can really
guarantee that it's going to solve the
task that you're looking for so yes
while that's a very hot topic
i think today's works if you read the
papers are still rather
require human intuition to do the
feature extraction great question though
right there
yeah great question i uh so if i
understood correctly the question is
about of that list of tasks in music
information retrieval which ones are
more solved than others
music fingerprinting is basically solved
uh companies like uh
gracenote which used the phillips
algorithm from the 90s
uh google
echo nest had an open source one that's
kind of
not that hard
uh other ones like a higher abstract
level like mood and genre still very
difficult and it's just there's this
level of human expectation that it's
it's not so much of a technical a
numbers problem but it's a
human expectation problem to be able to
identify
uh what the right mood is for whoever is
using a system at that time so those are
still difficult uh transcription will
may never be solved it's just it's
really hard to do if you have a
mahler symphony with 80 instruments on
stage then it's hard to extract every
single part
from the tuba to the harp to the
everything so that it's just a lot of
ill-posed problems in music information
retrieval and the more constraints that
you can impose upon a problem the better
the solution
great question yes
uh okay is the question in how you
detect the onsets or what do you do with
it
uh great question uh what what do you do
when you cannot detect onsets onset
detection is a very important part of a
lot of mrr systems but it's not
crucial i would say not every system
follows neatly the paradigm that i
showed you in these ipython notebooks
you may not need to extract every single
beat to do mood recognition
or genre recognition or artist
recognition uh those higher level tests
or songs structure identification i
don't think you need to do onset
detection so in those cases then you're
probably still fine but for those things
like music transcription
well
they you can maybe do onset detection in
a different domain like using nmf and
then doing onset detection in the
nmf factorized domain which is separate
from like the time domain itself or the
spectrogram domain itself
there are ways to get around uh that
yeah by by fact by doing like nmf and
then you look at each atom separately
then do onset detection there maybe
uh but it's still hard and i don't have
a firm answer for that good
beginning you talked question building a
search engine not just for music but
also for any type of sound talking
explosions how do you solve the um
segmentation problem you know it's
visual domain if you look at a picture
is this a car versus wheels
excellent question uh that's something i
really glossed over when you have when
you want to make a single decision
per audio signal yes you have one sick
audio signal it could be a second long
it could be a minute long it could be a
car honk or it could just be like a
saturday night live clip or something
like that you just want to make one
decision
often what people do is they'll build
some sort of characterization of of the
overall feature space using for example
gaussian mixture models so you'll get
your bag of features you'll parameterize
it using say a gaussian mixture model
and
from those locations of the gaussians
that is like a histogram that
characterizes that song now you've
standardized that
for a
an audio signal of any length so that's
often what people do
that's one thing
yeah uh the question was how does the
output of nmf differ from the fourier
transform
so uh
a free a transform is something that
switches between two domains the time
domain and the frequency domain
the input to a
fft module will be for example a time
domain signal literally an array
internally and the output will be a
two-dimensional array a matrix that is
complex valued that's a little bit
different from nmf which might follow on
to that nmf the input is a
two-dimensional array a matrix and the
output
is a pair
of matrices
a pair of two-dimensional arrays where
the columns of the first output
are the spectral content and the rows of
the second output are the temporal
content so those are two things that are
addressed a little bit different
problems and can be used in
series
right there
great point okay so uh the question was
can you uh say something about the
composition algorithm behind hometap uh
according to our attorneys no i can't
but if it were up to me i would i would
like i i'm just have this mindset where
i and say anything that i want but i got
yelled at a little bit so uh to answer
your question no i can't but there is a
composition algorithm so just the the
very premise of that question is uh
noteworthy uh there is music information
retrieval and then somehow you have to
compose music right from the inputs that
you put into the iphone so yes there's
something going on and then somehow we
have to render it
but i can't tell you more sorry
yeah
um
yep uh great question
yeah the question was uh well you saw in
the notebooks was mostly binary
classification what happens when you
want to do multi-class classification
where perhaps one class is a reject
option it's something that you might not
want to consider to be music because
it's not music
um
there's a lot of art behind that uh yes
there are different multi-class
strategies one versus rest one versus
one and so forth or you can have a
hierarchy of decisions which is actually
amongst one of the strategies that we
used in my previous company imagine
research when we wanted to build for
example a speech music
and other classifier because not
everything is speech and music so um
there you can work either hierarchically
or try to build just one multi-class
like three class classifiers speech
other in music they all have their
advantages and disadvantages and it's
just a matter of evaluating each one so
there is no uh
uh
unilateral answer if that's the right
word uh to your question but there are a
lot of there's a strategies
yeah great question yeah right here uh
so wondering do you know if anyone's
doing anything to predict whether a song
is going to be popular or not and
how do they do that yes and that's a
great question the question is can is
anybody predicting whether a song will
be popular more than you'd imagine there
are like actually a lot of people doing
that and both companies and in academics
you look at other data there's
a company called next big sound
nextbigsound.com located in new york and
what they're doing is not anything to my
understanding am i related but they look
at social media data related to music
tweets youtube views facebook posts even
like wikipedia edits stuff like that
for music so they can identify ahead of
time those diamonds in the rough those
hidden gems just like barcelona will try
to sign a 13 year old early on to with
the hopes that he is going to you know
make it big later on or even a
publishing house is going to find those
authors who might make them a lot of
money
recording labels are doing the same
thing right now and they're using tools
like next big sound with that money ball
philosophy and so they're trying to
correlate using previous data of how
they know musicians have become popular
mining that long tail of musicians which
is huge there are a lot of indian
musicians out there and using somehow
all that social media data to
predict popularity now some people
hypothesize that if you add music and
mir features acoustic features into that
that could improve it
that's
uh hasn't been proven either way but
there's a lot of work in that area great
question
last question right there
on that question
i know there are systems that do look at
the emir
man that's a great question think about
i was thinking about this you know
earlier today i was eating uh candy bars
i like because it's halloween time and
in the co-work space i work at there's
is just on the desk
and
you find that in areas all around our
life like in technology or food things
converge upon a dominant design that
they that there are some things that
just work better in some areas than
others like like candy bars and a nice
analogy that my ceo uses
to describe home tap is that imagine
it's like you're going into a restaurant
and you want to order a plate of food
well maybe in the restaurant of the
future
there is some
mixture of ingredients that is just
amazing and they know this from previous
data and they can make custom make a
plate of food that that specifically you
will love because they know things about
you
applying that to music is uh
it seems to already be happening maybe
not consciously the way that we're
thinking of like okay uh i know that c
major is popular so i'm going to make
something a c major but i think
subconsciously that's actually happening
right now in certain genres uh so
will that be a trend of the future and
do we want it to become a trend in the
future you know i i don't know but
that's just a great uh philosophy
question for us to ponder and we'll
leave you with that thank you very much